why following the disappointment of the
way you lost Saturday in Game one how
much of the way you guys came out
tonight and served that knockout punch
was a statement intentionally trying to
be made here you know we came out to
play defense tonight we had a mother a
hundred points last game we had a little
bit of communication issues on the floor
but tonight we came out aggressive on a
defensive and why you're a guy who's not
often in foul trouble to have three at
the half and still go on to score 20 in
the second half was that difficult for
you to play through that tonight and I
just kept my head in the game we wanted
to get this win and we're lucky leaders
and I'll get it done why the atmosphere
in this building tonight was intense
with what you guys were able to do just
the 11th game together as a group is
this the best Raptor basketball you
individually and this team has played
tonight
we had games earlier this season we
didn't even played a fourth quarter but
I mean it's our latest win so I guess
you could say that well I thank you good
luck the rest of the series all right
thank you
Kauai with all that you've been through
in the last year the injury the trade
getting adjusted to a new city how much
fun is it right now so know that your
one win away from advancing to the
second round this is what you play for
all season long and I'm just grateful to
be out here on the floor again feeling
good but took a long time for me to get
healthy but I'm happy I can go tonight
now now Hawaii told us this morning that
you played through Game three with the
flu and why you don't want to make any
excuses can you do it's a public service
announcement and let us know what you
did to get healthy what's the remedy
would be cure for the flu man just drink
a lot of water that's all I did
drink a lot of water took some of the
medicines you know the medical staff
gave me they did a great job
Kauai your defense tonight which
tremendous can you talk to what your
team was able to accomplish tonight I
think I'll play the rod defensively not
let a few drives get by me but my job
again like I said before we help them
win or a hundred points there's 45
points tonight and that's big for us
what do you think the environment is
going to be like Tuesday night and the
closeout opportunity for you well it's
gonna be amazing you know those fans
come out every every game regular season
and it's just the playoffs they've been
great just very exciting just appreciate
all the time for why good luck on
Tuesday we'll see you there scroll back
to you Leonard why you're leading
wire-to-wire every offensive search you
guys push back tremendous defense once
again what does it feel like to close
this one out and five oh man it feels
great just to close out
you know hopefully we got some time to
rest I'm not sure when we gonna play
again but we did a great job again I
said this before
once we play defense for our team to
beat and again we kept them under 100
points I got 96 tonight Nick nurse
stress yesterday that he wants this team
to carve out its own history what does
it mean to you to be such a huge part of
that
say that again I'm sorry said that you
guys are carving out your own history
and after this series I mean you are
such a monster part of that what does
that mean personally to you I mean
that's the goal you know we're trying to
get to the finals and you know we feel
like we got a group that could do it so
we just want to go every game leave it
all on the floor
so you know whatever happens and we
won't look back and say we could have
gave a better effort finally
Philadelphia currently up by over 30
points in their game against the
Brooklyn Nets if it is Philadelphia what
do you expect in the second round I'm
not sure yet I'm going to just enjoy
this win and night and you know once we
get to the drama Boris or fairly well
start thank you congratulations
all right cool what differentiates you
when the defense is right there in your
face and you still lay at those tough
shots well you know my teammates have
confidence in me I'll work on those
shots every day you know just went down
tonight I was able to knock it down all
right Thank You Kawhi we've gotta go
thank you
[Laughter]
exactly how he wants it came into this
game down to one you didn't know what
you're gonna get out of Seattle with his
leg injury so what was your mentality
coming into this
well just come in and play hard the
whole team concept was coming in and
play harder be smarter and take your
shots
Kyle Lowry and Marcus sold a lot of
discussion about them wanting to do more
in this game Kyle got off to a great
start and Mark gave you consistent
minutes how bad did you need it and how
much did you love it well we needed it
you know we're down to one on our home
floor for Game four and you know this
was a big win tonight you got to come
back and get it we're getting far after
these last two games what do you learn
the most about what you need to do to
win this area like I just said just come
out consistently come out play hard and
smart for the whole 48 minutes and we
should would a you know do what we want
you take us through that last play with
the pick and roll where you had a Joelle
embiid and hit that dagger three over
well Justin it was about three seconds
left on the clock
came off and you know he's long so I
just tried to fade away and shoot it
over the top of him and luckily it went
down Thank You Co bye guys thanks Mack
why was this the most complete game from
your team in this postseason top to
bottom yeah we made sauce tonight
once again
[Applause]
and like you said it was just a great
collective group group out the effort
out there to know
we end up getting a win one
it's talking to Danny Green before the
game he said he thought the key tonight
was rebounding for the second straight
game you guys out rebound Philly how
much is that a priority right now to get
on the glass I mean we definitely want
to hook them to one shot attempt on a on
their offensive end but if we make shots
we can rebound the basketball and how
many we got rebounding if we make shots
if we missing it's gonna be hard
tonight we made shots play great defense
as you just said one more left
what's it going to take to get a third
straight win a second straight win in
Philly and close this thing out perhaps
on Thursday that's the same thing we did
tonight come in hungry don't be
satisfied with tonight's win and be
ready to play congrats on tonight best
of luck Thursday
why why
you are a man of few words and you show
little emotion but how did that shot
make you feel great
I was just telling that we work on that
every day I'm just driving baseline I
said if I miss I'm lift the last was
short so I just wanted to put it up in
the air and got the shooters balance and
you had to work hard for it first you
got Ben Simmons on you you're driving
driving then Joe Mellon beat he's really
big he came up how did you have to time
it to get it over Joe L&B man just a lot
of hard work just wanted to my shot like
I said I just shot it as hard as I could
again and you see I got some pop gun and
they made the ball bounce off and end up
going in no I was just supporting listen
that free throw so I really wanted to
make that shot you played a lot of
minutes you knew you were going to play
a lot of minutes
how did you manage yourself throughout
the game to be able to come up big in
the fourth quarter I didn't really I'll
just try to play hard every possession
you know we could have went home I
wanted to just leave it all out on the
floor just in case we lost him
I would have been proud of myself you
know you're not going home you're
leading this team so the Eastern
Conference Finals but if you think about
your journey last season you only played
nine games you joined a new team with
the new head coach in a new country did
you have any doubts yeah last year was a
very dairy year for me I was going
through a lot for everything that was
going on and you know God is good
you know I prayed every day and then end
up getting healthy now I'm able to play
basketball and he's just shown you could
just see what he does for you I got one
more question
[Applause]
biggest concern
be honest
I mean the Bucks are very great team
they left the league this year I think
they were the only team with 60 wins and
I mean they're tough macho so you know
hopefully this guy said I'm prepared as
woman congratulations co-op wings fly
before this series you told me that the
key to this team success is everybody
just wants to win but where does your
mind go when your team looks to you to
take over you know confident in myself
my teammates are confident in me and
I'll just go out there and play and you
know I can live with the with the
results because I'm giving a hundred ten
percent out there you're defending an
MVP finalist in Yanis entity kupo what's
the key to limiting him offensively it
takes a team he's a great basketball
player that's why he's an MVP finalist
we all happen to show hands and just
play hard he's a great player he plays
hard and he's leading this team great
you did appear to be laboring physically
how are you feeling now all right this
is this playoff basketball everybody's
heard and so just got to keep fighting
and there's an opportunity now to tie
this series in Toronto despite the win
where do you want your team to be better
in Game four
gotta look at some film
right now I'm about to just enjoy this
win and we'll see what we got to do
tomorrow congratulations Kauai for you
guys Wyatt took chipping away at a
double-digit deficit but where did your
team find the advantage in the final
minutes we made shots and God stops on
the defensive end we got to limit them
in one shot their great offensive
rebound the team and great off as a team
we can't get them two or three looks at
the basket if a series doesn't start
until somebody wins on the road it
started tonight but how do you beat the
Bucks four times in a row I don't know I
haven't done it we're taking it one game
at a time and you know I'm just excited
that we got the win a night with one
went away until a trip to the NBA Finals
what's this teams mentality with history
on the line I mean I haven't even got in
the locker room yet we just finished the
game but I mean we wanted to come out of
here get the win we weathered the storm
early and let me say what we're gonna be
talking about a locker room
congratulations Kauai guys
time in franchise history the Raptors
are going to the NBA Finals how did you
approach this fourth-quarter comeback
I just want the one possession at a time
you can't fight an all-gay he was down
too
Foucault calls we're going our way but
we just kept striving and striving
you know when I was on that bench and it
started a fourth quarter my teammates
did a great job picking up that lead
after Game five you told me that you
didn't know how to beat the Bucks four
times in a row because he had never done
it and now you have what were the
changes that this team made after the
first two games of the series I think
we're more aggressive on the defensive
end now obviously we made shots guys
that was confident in knock down shots
you shared a moment with the Otters into
the cuoco at midcourt what did you have
to say to him the fun on the
congratulations to God he got a lot
better and just the key working finally
your thoughts on the upcoming challenge
that the defending champion warriors
represent oh man like you just said
hitter champions so we got to go in have
a mental focus and
enjoy the moment take the challenge
congratulations Kauai go celebrate
[Applause]
how'd that how'd that Kawhi Leonard
trade work out for you he's been
unbelievable is the best player in the
league
oh what happy he's in Toronto is his
nick nurse in the house here where's
Nick
kyle lowery no I know we got you both we
got you both I want to talk took a wife
first because when you when you look at
this game and I know that your head
coach Nick nurses said look even keel
when things are going well don't get too
carried away when they're down don't get
down tell me what was happening when you
were down 15 points late in the third
quarter and what the mindset was on this
team we was here you know last game in
the third quarter fourth quarter and we
just took our we just drive that in we
enjoyed the moment we went out there and
played hard every possession
you know when you know my teammates on
my back I went on a bench just to start
that fourth quarter they came back and
made a run Fred hit big shots norm you
seen kalo hit two big threes
back-to-back and you know surge
rebounding Martin hitting threes it's
just a collective effort and now that's
our mindset going there just playing
playing heart he's possessive you've
been a Finals MVP before this is a
pretty special situation when you come
to a team like this it's never been
there and now you're heading there how
does that register it with you mom so
it's still surreal to me right now you
know we just wanted Game six but you
know this one we've been striving for
our season everybody here will say get
to the finals and win it
I mean it's not over yet so we're gonna
try to win it tonight go on the locker
room and see what we got to do tomorrow
for the next for the next team
congratulations